Es ist gut, dass es jetzt so gekommen
ist, dass wir das jetzt plötzlich aufclustern
und sagen Na ja, aber das ist
eigentlich ein guter Migrant, das ist ja gar kein
richtiger Migrant, weil wir müssten
schon einen schicken Migrant haben.
Einer aus Uganda oder Tansania und einer aus Vietnam
und vielleicht noch
einer aus Syrien und dann sind wir richtig
gut divers aufgestellt. Und das ist
-nur eine Befriedung von Eitelkeiten.
-Die erste Frage von 13 Fragen, die
wichtigste Frage für heute: Brauchen
wir eine Migrationsquote? Wenn ihr sagt: Ja,
in so vielen Bereichen wie möglich,
geht ihr aufs grüne Feld, wenn ihr sagt: Nein,
auf gar keinen Fall geht ihr auf das gelbe
Feld. Wusstet ihr, dass Deutschland
nach den USA das größte
Einwanderungsland der Welt ist und jeder vierte, der hier
lebt, ist nicht hier geboren
oder zumindest ein Elternteil nicht?
Das bedeutet, wir sind ganz schön
divers. Darüber brauchen wir nicht diskutieren.
Aber ist diese Diversität nach außen
hin auch sichtbar in der Politik, in großen
Unternehmen? Bei eurem
Lieblingssendung z.B. hier bei 13 Fragen. Fakt ist
Menschen, die von Rassismus betroffen
sind, kommen an diese Position sehr viel
schwieriger. Bei 13 Fragen wollen wir diskutieren,
wie sich das verändern lässt.
Wäre eine Migrationsquote sinnvoll?
Ja oder nein? Grün oder gelb? Wo würdet
ihr stehen? Schreibt in die Kommentare.
Für euch jetzt nochmal ganz wichtig
bedeutet es, dass ab jetzt, wenn ihr der Gegenseite
zustimmt, dann geht ihr einen
Schritt nach vorne. Und wenn jemand
etwas sagt, was euch wütend macht, könnt
ihr das auch schon während des
Sprechens der anderen Person deutlich machen,
indem ihr einen Schritt
zurückgeht. Also ihr könnt das gerne organisch
in eure Bewegungen einfließen lassen.
Für mich ist natürlich irgendwie das Ziel,
euch heute so weit wie möglich
ins Kompromissfeld oder hier am besten
reinzubekommen. Hatice, ich würde gerne
direkt bei dir anfangen. Du bist in Berlin
geboren. Deine Eltern kommen aus der Türkei
und deine Jugend und Kindheit war
geprägt von wenig Geld, vielen
Vorurteilen und trotzdem hast du es geschafft. Du bist
jetzt Unternehmerin, hast es also
auch ohne eine Quote nach oben geschafft.
Warum hättest du dir denn
trotzdem eine Migrationsquote gewünscht?
Ich würde meinen Fall als Einzelfall,
Glücksfall bezeichnen. Nicht jeder hat so
viel Glück wie ich. Ich kenne das aus meiner
Familie, aus meinem Freundeskreis
sowie auch von meinen Zuschauern, die mir
jeden Tag schreiben, dass sie eben nicht
die gleichen Chancen haben und fragen
mich: Hey, was kann ich machen? Ich bin
frustriert. Und wie kannst du mir
helfen? Also kann ich nicht immer nur von meinem
Glücksfall ausgehen, sondern es gibt
genug Menschen, die keine Stimme haben
oder keine Plattform, um das kund
zu tun. Ich bin für eine Migrationsquote,
weil ich glaube, dass es Brücken
schaffen kann. Ich denke, dass unsere diverse
Gesellschaft zwar sichtbar ist, aber
noch nicht genug. Es fallen eben immer noch
-Menschen aus diesem Raster.
-Du hast dein Kopftuch damals abgelegt und
darin auch in vielen Interviews
darüber gesprochen, um überhaupt einen Job
zu bekommen. Damit empowerst du
viele deiner Zuschauer:innen, deiner Fans.
-Wie kam das überhaupt so weit?
-Ich habe mich als Gesundheits- und
Krankenpflegerin an einer Berliner
Krankenpflege Schule mit Hijab beworben
und als ich meine Papiere nicht
zurückbekommen habe, meine Bewerbung,
nachdem ich wirklich jahrelang
Absagen bekommen habe, dachte ich,
vielleicht liegt es ja am Kopftuch.
Also hab beim Fotografen ein Foto machen lassen
– ein Bewerbungsfoto ohne Kopftuch.
Habe es in der Kabine runtergenommen, habe mich
an derselben Krankenpflegeschule
beworben und hatte zwei Tage später
ein Vorstellungsgespräch. Also
war für mich hier die Frage: Okay, Job
ohne Kopftuch? Oder du behältst
dein Kopftuch und kein Job. Also ich hatte
-nicht so viele Möglichkeiten.
-Das wäre also ein Moment, wo dir so eine
-Migrationsquote geholfen hätte.
-Davon gehe ich aus.
Wo genau sollte denn
diese Quote eingeführt werden?
Ich denke auf jeden Fall
in der Ausbildung und Bildung.
-Ansonsten nicht?
-Ich finde, Unternehmen sollten die
Freiheit behalten, selber zu entscheiden,
die Leute so einzustellen. Vor allen
Dingen nach Qualifikation. Ich bin
selber Unternehmerin, was ich natürlich vom Staat
attraktiv finden würde, wenn wir z.B.
eben Steuerersparnisse bekommen könnten,
um zu sagen: Hey, hier ist ein alteingesessen
Unternehmen. Hier fehlen
einige Strukturen, um Leute eben
auch zu repräsentieren aus der Gesellschaft
und zu sagen: Okay, hier ist
dieses Angebot, das würde deinem Unternehmen
Steuervorteile bringen.
Möchtest du mal reinschauen?
Ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne dazu
positionieren zu dem, was Hatice gerade
gesagt hat. Katharina, du bist
einen Schritt auf sie zugegangen.
Ja, das finde ich tatsächlich einen
guten Vorschlag. Ich finde Positiv-Unterstützung
immer besser als eine Negativ-Subvention.
Ich glaube, das ist auch für viele
Unternehmen und auch für viele
Menschen, die vielleicht noch ein bestimmtes Mindset
haben, die sich vielleicht noch nicht
über alles schon Gedanken gemacht haben.
Ich glaube, dass das ein guter erster
Schritt wäre, tatsächlich. Persönlich habe
ich mit der Migrationsquote, weil ich kein
Migrationshintergrund habe,
keine Erfahrung gemacht. Aber mit der Frauenquote,
als ich selber politisch
aktiv war. Und ich kann nur sagen,
es fühlt sich nicht besonders gut an,
wenn man als Quotenfrau abgestempelt
wird und auch deswegen in ein Amt behoben wird
oder gehoben wird. Deswegen würde
ich das gerne auch allen anderen ersparen
und lieber dafür sorgen, dass es auf anderem
Wege funktioniert.
Jo, was sagst du dazu?
Du bist stehen geblieben.
Ja, ich fand die Idee mit den Unternehmen
durchaus auch sehr ansprechend
und auch richtig. Kann ich als Unternehmer
selber bestätigen. Dieses,
dass in Deutschland an den Schulen
die Quote angewendet werden sollte – das hab
ich nicht ganz verstanden, weil in Deutschland
hat jeder das Recht,
eine Schule zu besuchen. Und ja,
ich gebe dir recht, dass es für mich nicht
um Migrationsquoten geht, sondern um Chancen.
Und da geht es um Bildung.
Und da geht es aber auch darum, dass jeder
einzelne in den Rocky-Modus kommt
und die Chancen, die sich in diesem Land
einem jeden bieten, auch nutzt. Das ist so
ein bisschen für mich das Problem
bei der Migrationsquote. Da hab ich oftmals
das Gefühl, dass trotz der richtigen
Analyse des Problems der ein oder andere
durch durch die Ziellinie geschoben
werden soll, um das jetzt mal sehr überspitzt
auszudrücken. Denn das ist nicht fair
der Gesamtgesellschaft gegenüber. Wenn man
eine bestimmte Gruppierung aussucht
und diese dann aus der Sicht vieler dann
übervorteilt. Die Migrationsquote hat
das Potenzial, die Gesellschaft zu spalten,
weil es am Ende des Tages immer eine Frage
der Gerechtigkeit ist. Wen bevorzuge ich?
Wen benachteiligt es? Wer ist Migrant?
Aus welchem Land? Und zu wie viel Prozent?
Erfahrungen aus der Vergangenheit, die uns
gerade heute eine Lehre sein sollten,
dass wir die Gesellschaft so nicht
zusammenführen, sondern langfristig eher
-spalten.
-Hatice, kannst du das vielleicht mit der
-Schule nochmal erklären?
-Ich wollte meinen Hijab schon in der
Grundschule tragen. Wir sind nach Neukölln
mit meinen Eltern eine Neuköllner Schule.
Mit dem Kopftuch bin ich hingegangen
und ich wurde nicht genommen, weil sie gesagt
haben: Mädchen mit Kopftuch nehmen
wir an dieser Schule nicht an. Deswegen eben
schon. Vielleicht ist es auch hier
ein Einzelfall, aber …
Es ist kein Einzelfall, kann
ich dir hundertprozentig sagen.
Ich habe auch keinen Schulplatz
bekommen in der Grundschule, aufgrund meines
-Kopftuches.
-Diskriminierung aufgrund des Kopftuches
ist etwas, was wirklich
wissenschaftlich belegt ist. Wir haben einen Arbeitsmarkt,
der Frauen mit Kopftuch diskriminiert.
Und genau deswegen glaube ich, ist es total
wichtig, dass man Arbeitgeber
verpflichtet, dazu nachzudenken,
dass dieses Aussortieren entlang
von Merkmalsdimension nicht in Ordnung ist
und auch nicht zu vereinbaren mit unserem
Grundgesetz. Wir haben Religionsfreiheit.
Es sollte völlig okay sein, dass man
Muslim ist. Es dürfte kein Nachteil sein.
Wir haben im Moment das Problem, dass mit sehr viel
Selbstverständlichkeit eben
Ausgrenzung und Diskriminierung
stattfindet, weil sie einfach auch gar
keine negativen Konsequenzen zur Folge
haben. Und eine Quote würde einen dazu
-zwingen, anders nachzudenken.
-Joe, jetzt wo Hatice erzählt hat, dass es
bei ihr schon ganz früh anfing, dass sie andere
Chancen hatte als ihre weißen
Mitschüler:innen, die kein Kopftuch
getragen haben, gehst du da einen Schritt
auf sie zu und kannst
sie in dem Punkt verstehen?
Die Forderung nach einer Migrationsquote
kann natürlich befüllt werden mit vielen
einzelnen Geschichten. Ich weiß
aber nicht, ob man damit
der gesamtgesellschaftlichen
Friedensordnung gerecht wird. Ich bleibt
nach wie vor hier stehen, weil ich mich
nicht zur Gänze überzeugt, auch wenn mir
das für sie persönlich sehr leidtut.
Es gibt in dieser Gesellschaft
diese Probleme. Es gibt diese Ausgrenzungserfahrungen.
Ich glaube
nur nicht, dass eine Migrationsquote
der Schlüssel ist, um dieses Problem zu lösen.
Sondern ich glaube vielmehr, dass wir andere
Instrumente dafür brauchen.
Cahit, deine Eltern sind auch als Gastarbeiter:innen
nach Deutschland
gekommen. Heute bist du Lehrer am Gymnasium
und du würdest aber sagen:
Ich würde auf gar keinen Fall
aufgrund einer Quote eingestellt werden wollen.
-Warum?
-Ja, richtig. Denn ich glaube, dass es
schon darauf ankommt, dass man
Qualifikationen vorweist,
Kompetenzen vorweist, teamfähig ist
z.B. in den Unternehmen, indem man einsteigen
möchte, um mit den Teams
zusammenzuarbeiten. Und ich möchte ehrlich
gesagt nicht mit einem Quoten-Stigma
quasi in meinem Berufsleben oder meine Karriere
beginnen und der Quoten-Erfüller sein.
Ich möchte überzeugen mit dem was ich kann
und was ich bin und mitbringe. Ich habe
einen Migrationshintergrund und ich habe
allen Widrigkeiten entgegen mich
dennoch durchsetzen können. Das hat
meine Persönlichkeit geschärft
und ich glaube, dass es wichtig ist,
dass auch die Generationen, die nach uns
kommen, ihre Erfahrungen in einem freien
und offenen Wettbewerb machen. Ich gehöre
der zweiten Generation an und meine Eltern
sind vor 60 Jahren, in diesem Jahr
jährt sich das zum sechzigsten Mal
für unsere Familie, nach Deutschland
eingewandert. Ich hatte es nicht leicht.
Ganz klar. Ich bin ganz bei dir,
wenn du sagst: Es ist Zeit, dass man
diesen Rocky-Modus eröffnet
und wirklich auch kämpft und somit
auch seine Persönlichkeit bildet.
Mich hat das sehr gestärkt und ich weiß auch,
dass Diskriminierungserfahrungen
sehr verletzend sein können. Ich habe viele
Absagen bekommen. Ich habe viele
Probleme bei der Wohnungssuche gehabt
und dergleichen, keine Frage. Aber
dennoch bin ich kein Freund der Migrationsquote,
weil ich glaube, dass ich das z.B.
als Lehrer meinen Schülerinnen und Schülern
gar nicht vermitteln könnte. Etliche
von denen würden die Bücher wieder zuklappen
und sagen: Gut, wenn es auf das Lernen,
auf die Fähigkeiten, Kompetenzen nicht
ankommt, sondern nur auf die Hautfarbe,
meinen Glauben oder meine Herkunft,
um meine Karriere zu beginnen
oder eingestellt zu werden, dann weiß
ich nicht, womit wir dann junge
Menschen noch motivieren können und sollen,
-wirklich etwas zu erreichen.
-Nkechi ist dir einen Schritt
-entgegengekommen.
-Ich bin absolut seiner Meinung, dass es
ein Nachteil ist, wenn man
aufgrund einer Quote eingestellt ist,
dass das unter Umständen der Eindruck
entsteht, da steht jemand
nur weil er jetzt irgendwie eine Hautfarbe
hat zum Beispiel. Das ist
eine Problematik, aber die Idee, die dahinter
steht, ist ja nicht: Ich nehme
jemanden, der nichts kann und nur Muslim
ist, sondern die Idee ist, ich nehme
jemand, der was kann und Muslim ist.
Wir haben wahnsinnig gut qualifizierte Leute,
die regelmäßig Absagen bekommen, nur weil sie eben
dieses eine Merkmal haben. Es ist
andersherum gedacht. Ich glaube auch,
dass es unglaublich wichtig ist, darüber
zu sprechen, dass wir aus einer Ungleichsituation
eine Gleichheit
herstellen wollen und nicht jemanden
von irgendwo, der nichts kann, dann plötzlich
einen Job kriegt, der ihm nicht
zusteht, weil wenn wir es so kommunizieren,
dann wird es auch nicht den Effekt
haben, nämlich dass das akzeptiert wird.
Also ich möchte da gerne darauf
reagieren. Ich komme da gerne einen Schritt darauf
zu. Und zwar bei deinem Argument,
aus einer Ungleichsituation eine Gleichheit
zu schaffen, mehr Gleichheit zu schaffen.
Keine Frage. Wir haben natürlich
in unserem Land eine große Ungleichheit
in der Gesellschaft: Einkommensungleichheit,
Vermögensungleichheit, soziale
Ungleichheit, Bildungsgerechtigkeit.
Nachdem wir seit Jahrzehnten im Grunde
schreien und sich letztendlich immer noch
nichts eingefügt hat. Die Ungleichheit
muss aber anders bekämpft werden.
Können wir das tatsächlich nur mit der Migrations-
oder Migrantenquote erreichen?
Geht es denn nicht, indem wir Schülerinnen,
Schüler, Jugendliche,
Familien schon sehr früh fördern,
unterstützen? Bildung, Bildung, Bildung.
Das brauchen wir in diesem Land
tatsächlich. Darauf müssen wir setzen.
Auf der einen Seite Respekt,
Toleranz. Ganz wichtig. Wir dürfen nur eins nicht
vergessen, weil das gerade hier so
ein bisschen mehrfach durchgeklungen ist.
Ich glaube, wir sollten uns hier nicht
zu sehr auf einen antimuslimischen Rassismus,
den es sicherlich gibt, fokussieren
und dabei aber den Rassismus, den andere
erfahren – meine Schülerinnen,
Schüler indischer Herkunft, meine Schülerinnen,
Schüler afrikanischer Herkunft,
meine Schülerinnen, Schüler, die Juden sind
und über viele Jahre in der Schule
es verstecken und das nicht sagen,
dass sie jüdischen Glaubens sind, weil sie eben
nicht von der Mehrheitsgesellschaft
im Übrigen, sondern von der Einwanderungsgesellschaft
diskriminiert
-werden.
-Auf jeden Fall. Also hier möchte ich
-nochmal ganz kurz eingreifen.
-Das sind jetzt mehrere Sachen, die du
-gesagt hast.
-Ich muss ganz kurz einmal reingehen. Wer
genau alles durch diese Migrationsquote
vielleicht Vorteile bekommen könnte,
das können wir ja später noch genauer
ausdifferenzieren. Aber Nkechi, ich würde
gern nochmal auf dich zu sprechen
kommen, weil du vorhin gelacht hast. Warum?
Weil er sagte: Ja, wir müssen auf Respekt.
Wir brauchen Toleranz. Das sind alles
wunderbare Begriffe, die aber nicht mit Inhalt
gefüllt werden. Wir haben teilweise
auch in dem Bildungssektor, wo du
bist, das Problem, dass wir teilweise
mit Lehrpersonal zu tun haben, die sich
selber rassistisch äußern. Wie soll man
denn da ansetzen und sagen ihr müsst
tolerant werden? Das ist kein
Lösungsansatz. Wir brauchen
eher mehr Beschwerdestellen für Schüler
und Schülerinnen. Wir brauchen
Gesetze, die auch Menschen, die Kinder betreuen,
ganz klar verbieten, sie zu diskriminieren.
Diese Freiwilligkeit,
die wir ja haben – Toleranz,
Respekt – es gibt unglaublich viele wunderbare
Leitlinien, die existieren. Und dann
geht man auf den Schulhof und dann ist
die Realität da. Und das ist eine Diskrepanz,
mit der wir zu tun haben.
Und ich bin sehr der Meinung, das wäre
schön, wenn wir alle tolerant wären.
Aber wir benachteiligen. Wie diskriminieren.
Wir machen Sprüche.
Wir grenzen aus. Und solange
das stattfindet, ohne Konsequenzen,
ohne Sanktionen, wird es auch nicht
aufhören. Und das ist genau das,
was ich sage: Es muss sanktioniert
sein. Es muss Nachteile haben, wenn man es sich
z.B. als Arbeitgeber zur Gewohnheit
macht, alle ausländischen Namen auszusortieren.
Katharina hat sich einen Schritt nach hinten
bewegt, aber Hatice, was möchtest
-du dazu sagen?
-Ich wollte was zu dieser perfekten
Traumwelt sagen, also da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen: Ich wünschte, ich wäre
in dieser Welt groß geworden. Fakt
ist: Ich bin zu einer Berliner Hauptschule
gegangen, in Neukölln. Meine Eltern
konnten mir nie mit Mathematik helfen,
auch nicht mit Deutsch. Ich bin in die Schule
gegangen und meinen Zeugnissen
steht: Dieses Kind ist ständig
abwesend. Ich hatte niemanden, zu dem ich gehen
konnte: "Mami und hier ein bisschen
Bibi Blocksberg". Fakt ist, dass wir in sozial
schwachen Bezirken hier z.B. in Berlin
leider diese Traumwelt auch nicht haben.
Eigentlich freue ich mich über das, was du
gerade gesagt hast. Denn du hast nichts
anderes gesagt, als dass es um Bildung
geht. Und ich finde, du bist
ein hervorragendes Beispiel
dafür. Du hattest wirklich gar keine guten
Voraussetzungen. Aber du bist in den Rocky-Modus
gekommen und du hast dich
entschlossen, was aus deinem
Leben zu machen. Und heute stehst du hier.
Und warum reden wir eigentlich immer
über die Dinge, die nicht gut funktionieren?
Warum reden wir über die vielleicht
negativen Lebenserfahrungen? Ich fände
es wirklich toll, über die positiven
Lebenserfahrungen zu sprechen. Über dich.
Über die beiden Erfinder von BionTech,
die einer ganzen Nation Impfstoff schenken,
über Helden aus Kultur,
Kreativwirtschaft, Fußball, aus dem Journalismus oder aber
auch über Soziologen, die einen
Doktortitel haben und heute hier unter uns
weilen. Also wirklich diese Helden in den Mittelpunkt
zu stellen, um halt einfach
auch draußen ein Mindset zu verändern.
Wir konzentrieren uns immer
sehr auf eine negative Konnotation
und diese negative, anklagende Konnotation
führt immer dazu, dass irgendjemand
schuld sein muss. Und da ist es wahnsinnig
schwierig, Brücken zu bauen. Und deswegen bleibe
ich immer noch hier,
auch wenn ich die negative Erfahrung
zum Teil selber schon erlebt habe. Aber
ich finde, sich dagegen sträuben und versuchen
ein Vorbild zu sein – das ist
-doch das, was letzten Endes Brücken baut.
-Joe sagt Wir haben schon so viele
Vorbilder und Hatice, ich habe es vorhin
schon kurz angesprochen: Du bist ja
auch ein Vorbild für deine Zuschauer:innen,
für die Leute, die dir
folgen. Damit, dass du hier gerade
stehst und deine Geschichte erzählt. Man könnte
ja nach der Logik sagen: Du hast es geschafft
ohne eine Quote. Würdest du denn
sagen, um nochmal auf dieses Stigma-Thema
zurückzukommen, dass du kein Vorbild mehr
wärst, wenn du durch eine Migrationsquote
an genau diese Stelle gekommen wärst,
-wo du jetzt schon bist?
-Ich stimme ihm zu. Weder früher, noch
heute wollte ich überhaupt in eine Opferrolle
gesteckt werden. Noch möchte
ich, dass sich irgendjemand für meine Erfahrungen
entschuldigt. Das ist das,
was mich zu der Person gemacht, die ich heute
bin und das ist ein Puzzleteil
davon. Wenn mir jemand meine Geschichte,
diesen Teil wegnimmt, dann fehlt
was in meiner Geschichte. Und ich bin
letztendlich dankbar für diese Erfahrung.
Aber weil ich stark genug war. Du
warst stark genug, eben aus dieser Situation
herauszukommen. Aber ich kenne
ganz, ganz viele junge Menschen, die nicht
diese Stärke haben, die das extrem
zurückwirft, wenn sie eine Absage
bekommen. Also das ist auch eine Charakterstärke.
Nicht jeder kann
Rückschläge gut verkraften. Ich packe
jede Hürde an, egal welche ich habe.
Und die hab ich als Unternehmerin
jeden Tag, wenn der nächste Brief kommt,
die nächste E-Mail und ich nicht weiß,
was ich machen soll mit meinem erweiterten
Hauptschulabschluss. Aber ich stelle
mich dem und mache was und ich werde immer
erfolgreich. Aber das ist halt meine Hollywood-Geschichte.
Die hat leider nun
-mal nicht jeder.
-Katharina, kannst du das verstehen, was
Hatice gerade gesagt hat? Das ist
natürlich, wenn man davon ausgeht,
dass nur die, die die Stärksten sind,
die den meinetwegen größten Kampfgeist haben,
es irgendwie z.B. hier in diese Diskussionsrunde
schaffen.
Wollen wir dann eine Kampfgeistquote
einführen? Also ich meine, ich muss
genauso kämpfen. Ich sitz auch jeden
Tag da und weiß auch mal mit einem Brief
oder einer E-Mail nichts anzufangen
und bin Unternehmerin. Du hast vollkommen
richtig gesagt: Wir brauchen
Vorbilder. Das Vorbild, was du bist, das bin
ich vielleicht auch. Und vielleicht
sind wir es aus den gleichen Gründen,
nämlich gar nicht, weil du
ein Migrationshintergrund hast
oder weil ich privilegiert
aufgewachsen bin, sondern vielleicht, weil wir einfach
unsere Frau stehen in diesem Falle
und Unternehmerinnen sind und das auch schon
riesig viel wert ist in diesem Lande,
vollkommen egal, woher man kommt.
-Ich würde auch gerne noch was sagen.
-Er hat noch gar nichts gesagt.
Ich würde gleich zu dir
kommen. Ich hab dich auf dem Schirm.
Wir reden von Individualgeschichten
und davon, dass wir Vorbilder brauchen.
Wieso brauche ich ein Vorbild, wenn jemandem
Grundrechte nicht gewährleistet
werden? Wir reden von Grundrechten,
die kontinuierlich gewissen Leuten genommen
werden. Wir haben laut Grundgesetz
egal, welche Herkunft du hast, egal, ob du Mann
oder Frau bist, egal, welche Religion
du hast, sollst du gleiche Chancen haben
Aber dann ist die Quote genau da falsch.
Wenn wir eine Realität haben. in der es so
aussieht, dass du nur aufgrund von diesem Merkmal
bei gleicher Qualifikation keine
Zusage bekommst bzw. gleich
aussortiert wirst, dann haben wir ein Problem
in der Gleichheitsvorannahme und nicht
darüber, dass wir irgendwelche Vorbilder
brauchen oder fragen, hat es jetzt
eine aus 10 geschafft? Das sieht doch super
aus, da freuen wir uns jetzt.
Nein, wir freuen uns nicht, weil 10 andere
die Chance nicht gehabt haben.
Darum gehts doch. Niemand hier wird sagen,
dass wir da nicht noch besser
werden müssen. Ist doch überhaupt gar keine
Frage. Es geht aber letzten Endes
um die Diskussion, ob die Migrationsquote
der Schlüssel ist, um dieses Problem zu lösen.
Und gerade weil du aufgezählt hast,
nämlich den Gleichheitsgrundsatz,
genau da verstößt aus meiner Sicht
die Migrationsquote ganz erheblich.
Ich kann aber verstehen, dass man vielleicht
ein bisschen weiterdenken könnte
wie Amerika. Und wenn es darum geht, sich
zu bewerben, das Ganze anonymisiert
in irgendeiner Form durchführen müsste.
Also es gibt Mechanismen, wo ich sage:
Warum denken wir da nicht ein bisschen
quer? Und es ist nicht nur eine Frage
von Migrant oder nicht Migrant. Menschen,
die behindert sind oder was auch immer
für Eigenschaften haben, müssen im Grunde
genommen einem Idealbild weichen. Und das kann
nicht sein. Wenn unser erster Artikel
sagt: Die Würde des Menschen ist
unantastbar. Da kann ich sagen: Lasst uns
doch mal an einer Lösung
zusammenarbeiten. Wunderbar.
Ich sehe die Quote auch nicht als einzigen
wichtigen Weg. Ich sehe die Quote
als einen von vielleicht ein Potpourri
von 10 verschiedenen Sachen.
Da können wir uns
gerne drüber unterhalten.
Wo wir dran dran arbeiten. Das eigentliche
Ziel, nämlich Diskriminierung abzubauen.
Was ist denn der Grund, warum jemand
diskriminiert wird? Wir haben
Zuschreibungen, die automatisch
an jede Person, die dieses Merkmal hat,
übertragen wird. Daran müssen wir arbeiten.
Aber wir haben die Realität,
dass wir massive Vorurteile haben und dass die angewandt
werden. Und sie werden
in allen möglichen
gesellschaftlichen Bereichen angewandt – im Wohnungsmarkt,
-im Arbeitsmarkt, in der Schule.
-Aber das Problem löst du nicht Top-Down.
Unbedingt sogar. Es muss
sanktioniert werden.
Nein, das ist genau der Unterschied.
Ich glaube, das musst du von unten nach oben
-lösen und nicht Top-Down.
-Aber wie soll denn ein Schüler einen
Lehrer verändern? Ich würde jetzt
gern endlich mal Michael reinholen, sorry.
Michael, du bist nicht von Rassismus
betroffen und trotzdem stehst du hier
auf der Seite für die Migrationsquote?
Würdest du dann sagen, dass unsere diverse
Gesellschaft sichtbar ist, z.B. in der Politik,
in den Medien, in großen
-Unternehmen?
-Ich würde mir vor allem sehr oft mehr
Differenzierung wünschen. Also z.B.
ich musste noch nie kämpfen. Ich habe hart
gearbeitet, aber ich habe noch nie
kämpfen müssen für ein Menschenrecht. Ich hatte
jeden Zugang zu Bildung, zu Gesundheit
etc. Und so geht es glaube ich sehr vielen
weißen, privilegierten Menschen und das ist
erst einmal wichtig festzuhalten.
Deswegen gibt's einen großen
Unterschied zwischen kämpfen und zwischen hart
arbeiten. Mir ist das Thema sehr wichtig,
weil ich in einer sehr diversen
Gesellschaft mittlerweile leben darf
durch die Arbeit von Viva con Agua. Dadurch,
dass wir Viva con Agua hier in Südafrika,
in Mosambik, in Uganda haben, dadurch,
dass ich sehr viele Menschen
kennengelernt habe, die meine Perspektiven und Horizonte
maximal erweitert haben. Und deswegen kämpfe
ich vielleicht auch ein bisschen
mit ihnen und für sie. Des Weiteren
glaube ich, dass es nicht um entweder oder geht,
sondern sowohl als auch. Und wir kommen
aus einem Ungleichgewicht und das kann man
sich in jeder Studie anschauen.
Deswegen würde ich aus meiner Sicht sagen,
die Quote wäre gut, um zu übersteuern.
Natürlich ist es eine Übersteuerung
und natürlich kommt ein Stigma mit.
Und deswegen muss man auch differenzieren
und genau hinschauen. Die Welt ist
sehr komplex, in der wir leben. Das heißt,
ich muss eigentlich ein Rassismusexperte,
ein Diskriminierungs- und Sexismusexperte
etc. sein. Das ist aber meines
Erachtens die Aufgabe der Politik, die komplexe
Sachverhalte zu verstehen und Strukturen
zu schaffen, die langfristig zum Besten
aller Wesen sind. Und das in einer komplexen
Welt, das schaffe ich nicht
als Unternehmer. Deswegen würde ich mir
da natürlich Hilfestellung und starke
Strukturen wünschen, die zum Besten
aller Wesen sind und nicht nur eine weiße,
privilegierte Schicht, die gar nicht
mehr repräsentiert, was Deutschland ist.
25 Prozent sind Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund.
Deswegen haben
die haben teilweise andere
Bedürfnisse, andere Herkunft, andere Kulturen,
die ich gar nicht als Unternehmer
zum Teil kennen kann.
Geht ihr da einen Schritt auf ihn zu?
Also versteht ihr Micha, dass ihr diese Quote
bräuchtet, um das überhaupt
erst durchsetzen?
Ich hab da ein Verständnisproblem. Und zwar
wenn man von Migrationsquote spricht,
schließt das den Letten
mit ein und den Ukrainer mit ein?
Das können wir gerne
heute zusammen diskutieren.
Darauf möchte ich jetzt gerne
eingehen, weil ich kann natürlich sagen: Natürlich,
Migrationsquote wunderbar. Also dann
suche ich in Lettland nach einer aparten
Persönlichkeit, in der Ukraine und bestimmt
kommt aus Holland auch jemand
um die Kurve, dann habe ich die Quote
erfüllt. Ist damit das Problem gelöst
oder ist es nicht gelöst? Ganz kurz:
Ich glaube, dass das Problem durchaus richtig
erkannt ist. Dass da etwas passieren
muss, das ist unstrittig. Aber ich glaube,
dass die neue Generation, die heranwächst,
viele, die da an allen unterschiedlichen
Ecken und Enden schrauben, da das Bewusstsein
in harter Arbeit werden ändern
können. Aber hinzugehen und das ist
gut, dass es jetzt so gekommen ist,
dass wir das jetzt plötzlich
aufklustern und dann sagen: Naja, aber das ist
eigentlich gar kein guter
Migrant, der ist gar kein richtiger Migrant,
weil wir müssen schon einen
schicken Migrant haben, einen aus Uganda
oder Tansania und einen aus dem Vietnam
und vielleicht noch einen aus Syrien.
Wo es jeder sieht, dann sind wir richtig
gut divers aufgestellt. Und das ist
nur eine Befriedigung von Eitelkeiten.
Aber das legt doch erstens die Axt
an die Menschenwürde, die wir in diesem Land
doch so gross schreiben, und zweitens
glaube ich, dass wir uns daran
gewöhnen müssen, dass wir von oben verordnete
Lösungsmodelle so nicht
werden durchkriegen können, weil immer
eine andere benachteiligte Gruppe
sich melden wird und sagen wird: Moment mal,
aber ich auch! Ich auch! Und ich möchte
auch neben der Migrantenquote eine Quote
für xy haben. Dann haben wir so
viele Quoten, dass dann irgendwann mal
die Mehrheitsgesellschaft sich fragt:
Wann kriegen wir denn eigentlich unsere Quote?
Weil wir haben das Land aufgebaut und danach
hast du nämlich eine ganz spannende
-Diskussion.
-Siehst du das auch so, Micha?
Nee, ich glaube, du sprichst die Gesellschaft
an und die Gesellschaft ist
eben alles. Und da ist ein Teil
die politischen Strukturen, in denen
wir leben. Und es geht um Machtverteilung
und Machtstrukturen. Und wenn man sich
alle Zahlen anschaut: Ich heiße
Michael und Andreas sind zwei wirklich deutsche,
typische, oft langweilige Namen, die in allen
Vorständen sitzen, zu 46 Prozent
oder so. Also schon alleine wenn wir die Analogie
zur Frauenquote haben: Wo sind
in den Dax-Unternehmen die Frauen? Wo sind
die Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
-in den Dax-Unternehmen?
-In den Dax-Unternehmen sind aber auch
keine Arbeiterkinder in den Vorständen.
Schau dir die Studien an, die sind
ebenfalls unterrepräsentiert. So
wie die Arbeiterkinder zum Beispiel
an den Universitäten
unterrepräsentiert sind. Auch dort gibt es kaum welche.
Am Ende geht's auch da wieder
um Zugang, Zugang zu Bildung.
-Ganz genau.
-Da sind wir uns ja alle, glaube ich,
einig. Und dieses Ungleichgewicht
muss aufgelöst werden. Und da ist wieder
nochmal die Migrationsquote
nur ein Mittel, um dorthin zu kommen
und da brauchen wir noch viel mehr
Mittel. Ich glaube aber, das Spiel bräuchte mehr
Farben, um die Diversität und die Problematiken
und die Herausforderungen,
in denen wir sind, darzustellen. Da ist
eben Grün und Gelb vielleicht zu wenig
Farben, wie genauso schwarz und weiß
zu wenig sind. Und wir brauchen da viel mehr
Spielraum und auch viel mehr
spielerischen Umgang damit. Damit es egal ist,
ob Schwede, Italiener, Ugander what
ever. Es geht darum, dass wir eine diverse
Gesellschaft haben, die dann auch diverse
Lösungsansätze für die Herausforderungen,
-in denen wir stehen, bringt.
-So, gehen wir über in die Kompromissrunde.
Ich schlage euch jetzt erst mal
einen Kompromiss vor und dann seid ihr dran
mit den Kompromissen. 11. Frage
von 13 Fragen: Sind wir uns einig,
dass unsere diverse Gesellschaft
in wichtigen Bereichen wie Unternehmen,
Politik oder auch Medien, also
Internet, Radio und TV nicht genug sichtbar ist?
Wenn ihr sagt ja, dann könnt ihr jetzt
einen Schritt auf mich zugehen. Das war
ein doller Schritt. Ihr wackelt
alles ein bisschen. So ein halbes, ja. Okay,
jetzt gebe ich euch Zeit, dass ihr die Köpfe
zusammenstecken könnt und selber
überlegen könnt, was wäre von eurer
Seite aus ein Kompromissvorschlag für die andere
-Seite.
-Ich habe noch mal genauer geguckt, aber es
gibt wirklich da ne
Datenlage zu und keiner tut was dagegen.
An die, die ihr gerade zuschaut:
Was wäre denn euer Kompromissvorschlag,
wenn ihr euch hier jetzt gerade auf eine Seite
stellen könntet? Schreibt es mir
-in die Kommentare.
-Das mal akzeptieren: Okay, check, wir
-haben ein Rassismusproblem.
-Was ist euer Kompromissvorschlag an die
-andere Seite?
-Also wir wären auf jeden Fall gegen eine
starre Quote. Aber wir brauchen
mehr Awareness in den Unternehmen.
Deswegen wären wir dafür, so wie es den Datenschutzbeauftragten
gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben gibt, auch einen
Diversity-Beauftragten im Unternehmen
zu haben oder eine Beauftragte, die dann
auch regelmäßig Schulungen tatsächlich
durchführt. Und wir wären auch für die Positiv
Subventionierung, das heißt
ein Steuererlass zum Beispiel bei Unternehmen,
das ist in öffentlichen
Unternehmen schwer umsetzbar, aber
zumindest bei den Privatunternehmen wäre
das auf jeden Fall was, was unterstützen
könnte ohne eine Quote.
Und, geht ihr einen
Schritt auf die gelbe Seite zu?
00:27:31,890 --> 00:27:31,790
-Ja.
Okay. Die Seite, die für die Migrationsquote
ist, kann jetzt auch einen
-Kompromissvorschlag machen.
-Wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir die Quote
zwar immer noch wollen, aber
gerne einbetten wollen noch in mehrere
Sensibilisierungangebote, dass sie,
sobald es wieder eine Verbesserung
der Ungleichheit gibt, auch wieder
abschaffen würden. Dass es ganz wichtig
ist, bevor die Quote kommt, dass klar
ist, dass wir eine Anerkennung haben darüber,
dass es Diskriminierung gibt, dass wir das erreichen,
dass wir auf der Basis
dieser Anerkennung von Ungleichheit
dann die Quote einführen. Also nicht im Sinne
von "so wir machen jetzt die Quote
ohne irgendeinen Grund", sondern dass die gut
-begründet ist und verstanden wird.
-Würdet ihr einen Schritt auf die andere
-Seite zugehen?
-Na bei dem Argument sofort.
-Einen halben Schritt gehe ich gerne mit.
-Joe nicht? Du hast dich echt wenig bewegt.
Ja, das stimmt, weil ich mich mit der Quote
einfach wahnsinnig schwer tue.
Das ist für mich ein aktivistisches
Instrument, um einen Punkt auf die Agenda
zu bringen. Aber das ist kein
Schlüssel zur Lösung des Problems. Deswegen wäre
-das für mich ein fauler Kompromiss.
-Ich bin schon mit offenen Armen hier her
gekommen, weil ich super
gespannt war auf eure Argumente,
-die ich auch sehr berechtigt fand.
-Ich fand es auch spannend. Es war ein
sehr, sehr interessantes Thema, auch ein kompliziertes
Thema, muss ich sagen.
Aber ich fand den Umgang
miteinander und wie wir uns diesem Thema gemeinsam
genähert haben, fand
ich wirklich sehr toll.
-Ja, finde ich auch.
-Also meine große Sorge ist, dass die
Bundestagswahlen tatsächlich von manchen
Parteien oder Gruppierungen dazu genutzt
werden, auf dem Rücken der Migranten
letztendlich Wählerstimmen zu gewinnen.
-Ja, das wäre traurig.
-Und ich würde mir wünschen, wenn vor allem
die demokratischen Parteien hier
ein deutliches Zeichen setzen und sich
-dem nicht ergeben.
-Ich hoffe, dass es nicht in der Wahl zum
Thema wird, weil wenn in Wahlen
diskutiert wird, ist es meistens wohl eher
populistisch und polarisierend und wirklich
nicht hilfreich für hier lebende
Menschen, sondern am besten
nach der Wahl, nach dem Wahljahr,
nach dem Integrationsgipfel,
einfach danach Verbindlichkeiten erarbeiten
und wir wünschen uns, dass nach dem Gipfel
ein Umsetzungsgremium noch da ist,
dass das Ganze dann
umsetzt, was wir uns wünschen.
Ich habe jetzt am Ende zumindest
viele nickende Köpfe gesehen und ihr seid euch
zumindest näher gekommen. Vielen,
vielen Dank für die Diskussion und fürs Teilen
-eurer Gedanken.
-Danke schön.